enzo quatre ans et attendent une maladie
neuromusculaire à la myasthénie
congénitale il prend part à cette course
grâce à une geôle est un fauteuil tout
terrain
c'est la première fois que sa mère cindy
peut courir à ses côtés c'est un combat
de tous les jours
il a un traitement mais le quotidien au
quotidien ça ne l'aide pas c'est ça le
guérit pas en fait ça va l'aider à
marcher il va marcher deux minutes
voilà c'est un combat de tous les jours
il ya les soins il a eu dernièrement une
gastrostomie pour pouvoir être nourri
par l'estomac
cette course solidaire s'est déroulé
pendant le temps du déjeuner afin de
permettre à des salariés de participer
350 salariés cours pour la bonne cause
trois parcours étaient proposés c'était
10 km c'est vrai était rapidement il ya
pas mal de monter donc on est rapidement
surpris mais en fait au final ça va ça
se fait c'est dans un cadre très
agréable et c'est vrai que quand c'est
la pensée pour la bonne cause autant
forcer l'intégralité des profits de cet
événement sont reversés aux associations
les restes du coeur l'enfant bleu et les
dunes de l'espoir l'idée de départ qu'on
a eu c'est en gros
de créer un événement solidaire et
sportif solidaire c'est à dire on prend
l'argent mais on reverse la totalité de
ce qu'on a et on regarde en rien pour
nous en trois éditions les marcassins du
coeur ont reversé plus de 15000 euros